doing probiotics how's it going man
Michael Alan good to meet you cool
what's your unto your company
Osiris Osiris yeah and that one is the
we're trying to cool nice yeah no
worries thanks for building what you're
building oh yeah that's such a smart
idea yeah get a notification you're like
oh my god someone's hurt you know two
minutes away from me I can get there
faster yeah yeah so smart good stuff hi
everyone hey Mike Mike right no Brian
Brian that's right yeah but I brought
him from which one again new age new age
pork right pork yeah one thing here
today to talk about why you guys should
listen to Alan is he's among the best
people I've ever seen it like creating
new and maintaining relationships I know
nothing but thank you Alan is a sponge
and also brings together like a really
people who are so today he's kind of
talking about how to reach out and build
these connections so it is a very soft
skill driven kind of thing but it's very
important for all your companies finding
people who are champions and advisers
and all
it's all that you give more of a
background and then thanks Alex
thank you very much Alex that was
extremely kind I know nothing and I'm
just trying to do my best to build the
bright future as are you guys you guys
know the hard stuff the biology the code
of life right that's tough stuff and I
appreciate you guys so much for taking
this risk speak up even louder or I'll
speak up even louder okay all right
let's see here let's try this alright
can you hear me better now alright let's
go with this volume then okay so you
guys already took the first risk so this
is about building high profile
connections to maximize the success of
what you are working on so you already
took the first risk look at all of you
here how many of you could have easily
been like I don't want to be an
entrepreneur all of you and you chose to
be an entrepreneur and you chose to
pursue this crazy rollercoaster ride of
building something of high value into
the world all right so now you're on
this you're on the roller-coaster you're
moving forward how do you accelerate
your success how do you succeed most
optimally with maximal intention of
catalyzing significant impact not just
small impact or medium impact with
maximal impact so let's go ahead and
jump into this I'm going to try and keep
this interactive so actually if at any
point you guys want to chime in just
raise your hand and chime in okay can we
get on a conversational page yeah all
right cool all right good good to hear
so good to hear your voices alright so I
host a show called simulation we feature
scientists entrepreneurs technologists
educators all different types of people
everything from blockchain and AI to
biotech to neuroscience to geopolitics
emotional intelligence all this type of
stuff and why we do it is because we
know that the public intellectual needs
to be rebirthed and we need to inspire
the next generations to build the future
so it's time to focus more on science
technology entrepreneurship let's get
that rolling in our world so the first
big point is risk
risk you're already here you came here
today so now the next step is how do you
get to that high profile connection that
you really want to talk to whether that
be an investor that be somebody that
wants to partner up with you that
somebody that wants to buy a lot of what
you're making how do you go out and
reach out to that person build a good
relationship with them and we'll unpack
that but taking the risk is the first
step you have to do it you have to admit
to yourself that I know nothing and I'm
gonna go and fall on my face a bunch of
times along the way and be totally okay
with that process does that sound
familiar
the falling on your face along the way
the struggle yeah because we that's
that's this whole roller coaster ride we
got to become more and more adaptive to
the failures and reintegrate them along
the way
so we've already mentioned this you're
here you already took the first risk so
the next big thing is finding who your
superstars are how many of you know your
top three or top five candidates that
you want of your really high profile
connections for investment or for sales
how many of you already have those
outlined so one team out of the teams
has that outline so your first piece of
advice and homework is to tonight go
home and start or even in 45 minutes
when you go back and sit down just go
and write down in a note write down your
top people that would catalyze your
success tremendously that means advisers
people that would buy a lot of your
product partnerships etc go and do that
does that make sense as a first piece of
advice okay we got like we are like 60%
of heads nodding what about the other 40
yes okay all right so go and make that
list that lists this first key first
point the next part the list is going to
be how do the next part is how to
approach them we're going to talk about
the tactics as well we've got to be okay
with failure we know that it's going to
end up happening no matter what we're
gonna stumble fall on our face but we're
gonna reintegrate what we learn back
into our practice and we're gonna become
better do we already feel ourselves
becoming better at what we do how what
one week ago one month ago even we
weren't as good as we are today at what
we do right so we're slowly growing and
becoming bad
which means that you reach out to one of
these high-profile connections they
might not respond but that's not going
to hold us back from being persistent
that's a major key here is being
persistent reaching back out again maybe
after two weeks and saying hey how is
this door is this do you want to talk
are you interested at all I'd love to
help in some way and we'll talk about
this is this is weird this comes out of
left field you're like gene expression
what is that anything to do with a
building high-profile connections so
this is actually takes a different look
at what we've been talking about on one
side we're talking about turning on the
expressions to the high profile
connections I also want to make it clear
that we're going to be turning off the
expressions to less important
connections I have a big head nodding
going on here you're like I know you're
like I know you can waste a lot of time
and get distracted so knowing who to
slow down talking to is equally as
important as who you should be talking
to okay so maybe within this list let's
let's actually assign this as a piece of
homework as well that write down the top
five people that we need to reach out to
for Superstars but also the top five
people that we need to spend a little
bit less time talking to so we can focus
our time on the bigger picture on the
vision on the execution on the strong
connections that we need to build yeah
sound good I know can be tough right
because it it's emotionally it hurts to
say that I have to not talk I have to
not respond but people get it people get
it over time I'm sorry I'm really
focused I'm really heads-down be very
kind about it and then just don't
respond you guys are yeah it's tough but
we got we got we got to do that that's a
good way to stay focused and write that
down write that down as well who do we
not talk to as well as who do we talk to
so continue taking these risks you're
already here now it's time to talk to
the bigger connections go and take the
risk okay part two is these tactics
so now you know okay Alan I know I need
a go and take the risk how do I take the
risk what is our best procedure for
taking these risks well the first step
is friendship first so I'm not coming in
there what was your name David David
awesome so I'm not coming into an email
with David and saying hey David do you
want to invest in my company that that
will work very very small percentage of
time it's more often something like hey
David I like what you're building I like
what you're working on how can I be of
help can we take a meeting to chat and
so in that's and from that perspective
what you're doing is you're coming in
you know that this that the person David
is a superstar and you want to talk to
David but you're not immediately saying
this is how you can help me you're
saying how can I help you how can we be
friends first so you go and you take
this meeting and a bunch of people are
going to tell you no but then sometimes
people are going to tell you yes when
you sit down with them
you want to really get to know them you
want to get to know them why are you
building what you're building why do you
care about this why do you care about
this endeavor you're pursuing in biotech
tell me more about yourself why you care
about it how can I be of help I know
some scientists some entrepreneurs maybe
maybe there are some ways that I can
help you and then the idea of this is
all asking questions and helping them
over time you're actually going to
realize that you're gonna be asking them
questions and they're gonna be giving
you advice you're gonna be asking them
questions like oh how did you how did
you end up raising money you're asking
them a question they're teaching you how
they raised money you're learning about
how they raised money how did you strike
that partnership with X company oh you
did it this way they're teaching you
again you're getting advice and you're
staying humble and having an awareness
of reciprocation is David going and
asking me afterward he's like oh now
like what do you need because if they're
not asking you what you need in this
meeting then typically that means that
they're not expressing as much interest
but we still have to know what our ask
is and take that risk with them meaning
we're still going to either at the end
of that meeting or at
end of another meeting down the line we
still want to put we still want to
gently nudge in the direction of what we
need in order for us to grow which is if
I've been learning about how to strike
up this partnership or how to raise
money that I will I will go and make
make it clear that I'm currently in the
process of also striking up a really
important partnership you know
are you actually connected to anybody
that could help out with that so even a
simple ask like that oh actually I might
be or I'm not and then slowly you're
opening up more doors and as you open up
more doors more doors open up but you've
got to be willing to take the risk and
be tactful along the way in order to
maximize the success of what you're
doing people are gonna tell you know
you've got to follow up persistence is a
huge key in this game people are not
gonna reply how often you know we were
just talking about how often we don't
reply to people when you don't reply to
somebody do they ping you again yeah it
happens and so what we see is that we do
that same thing to other people to
superstars if they're not replying to us
after a week or after two weeks just
follow up again be persistent you never
know when you knock a second time when
the door can open and these are really
important doors that will open and
catalyze some big success so in summary
take risks be tactful okay I'm gonna
walk us through an activity as well and
more engagement in interaction because
we still have a bunch of time but I
don't want to sit here in monologue I
want us to engage and interact about
what actually are things that are going
on with you and how we can be helpful
for even observing what this dialogue is
gonna look like right now so if you guys
want to reach out I'm open I'm an open
book reach out to me please I'd love to
help out I love biotech I love
accelerating the success of people that
are trying to change the future and also
learning from you because I know nothing
I'm trying to learn a lot more about
biotech so reach out do you guys have
questions for me before I engage with
you
no any questions that come to mind yeah
someone's just on your list yeah that's
a that's a really great question so okay
so now we have our list of five
Superstars and we have our list of five
people that we need to talk to less
we've made this list the list is very
clear now we need to make action so on
the side of superstars a really really
interesting way that we we typically
don't even think that that this is even
a possibility but the warmer the
connection the better it is and we don't
even know who we're connected to in our
network our node our network extensions
they're like the roots of a tree of like
a massive rain forest we don't even know
who were connected to until you go and
you start looking on your Facebook
looking on your LinkedIn and you start
exploring the connection networks all of
a sudden you realize that you have a
friend that's already connected to that
person so you already have a warm intro
to them we didn't even know that we did
so go and look on LinkedIn find who that
who a first connection to them is or a
Facebook friend is and then seriously
just go to their profile find their
mutual friends and then you see oh crap
like Paul's a mutual friend or Sally's a
mutual friend great message Sally asked
hey Sally will you please introduce me
to David and then at that point then
Sally will make a quick introduction to
David and you have to send our sentence
we have to make these things easy for
warm intros make it easy
meaning send her a sentence about your
company one one sentence really easy you
know Osiris right
so for Osiris you know how to pitch this
much better than I do but a making
emergency response more effective and
just really simple stuff with the link
to your website and and and then Sally
will copy and paste that and into the
intro to David okay so making it really
easy for these warm connections I'm
gonna hit that quote I'm gonna hit that
in a second because that was warm right
now you're like okay how the hell do I
do cold intros because a lot of these
people these superstars we don't even
know we don't know they're actually
disconnected from us by quite a bunch of
networks that we don't even that were
not near so okay so for colder intros
it's there's there's a lot of different
software that enables you to pull
people's email right now from the
internet there's different plugins like
contact out is really good there's a
couple other ones that are really good
at this but rocket reach there's all
these that are just super good at this
but what you do is you just literally
copy and paste their LinkedIn you go to
their LinkedIn use to plug in and then
you copy and paste their email that
populates and you can send them a direct
email unless you can find it online
sometimes people listed on their
LinkedIn sometimes they listed on blogs
that they've written so just a google
search of david with your last name Sing
se same say David's say and then email
address on Google search David say email
address you'll be surprised at how often
will populate on Google search then you
can get their email and reach out to
them cold now the message body for when
you reach out to them cold again very
short how many of us get five paragraph
emails and we're like [ __ ] that's
overwhelming yeah okay how many of us
get like two sentence emails and we're
like I can respond right away right two
sentence email hey David love your work
I'd love to see how I can help out you
want to take a quick tea on Wednesday at
noon that's it
super simple just like that and you know
when you go meet them yep
yep exactly so this that's perfect who
the [ __ ] is this exactly exactly so you
know hi David
love your work I would love to help out
I'm building osiris advancing emergency
response with link and then we'd love to
meet 40 Wednesday noon does that work
for you you know so so literally it's
it's almost like yeah it's almost like
two-sentence with the space in between
what you can what you want to do you
first say I want to help and then you
say this is what I'm building not saying
but not saying invest in my company or
provide me with something but yeah
exactly
but then the then they're aware of what
you're building too which you definitely
want them to be aware of what you're
building as well yes yeah
so that would be warm and cold for that
yeah awesome cool let's yeah let's keep
it as simple as possible and also knock
on as many doors as possible yes yes
that's that's a that's a great question
so how valuable is that super star
connection to you because if the super
star connection is very valuable then
and then it depends on your relationship
with Sally as well because obviously
there's a massive spectrum here you can
be not close at all or be very close to
her Sally
so then how much effort do you want to
put into building the relationship with
her well I first personally I don't even
take a meeting with Sally I just DM
Sally and I say hey Sally
I'd love I hope you're well I'd love to
connect to Paul Richardson whatever
because I think I can help him and he
can help me exactly do try to spend try
to spend try to figure out how to spend
30 seconds on each one of these like
outreaches or 60 seconds if you're
spending an hour drafting up an email we
are not doing things right so this base
copy and paste we just we just made this
we just made this email it can literally
work this cold email can work it's copy
and paste it is Sally love your work I
want to I want to help out this is what
I'm building into the world can you take
a meeting at noon next week 40 and just
copy and paste that for for Paula for
Ricardo etc yeah yeah change the name
change the name and you know change the
name and in actually if you can add a
personalization touch very small one
love what you're building with blank
right so just add that personalization
touch as well then they'll be like okay
they already know what I'm building with
my company so they'll so they'll see
that you're you've researched them a
little bit and you and you you know you
want to add those personal touches the
friendship first touches yeah that's a
great question as well I personally love
interpersonal stuff and I think
interpersonal stuff catalyzes totally
different energetics than phone called
us and the energetics from an in person
can typically rock it a relationship
forward versus phone call but sometimes
people will say if they're in Mountain
View and you're up here yeah or if
they're New York yeah then phone call
yeah
no I feel like I'd be more like they
doesn't take a phone call first
like going out
let's go yeah just to just to address
that quick think about the risk if
you're willing to take the risk of
taking that meeting that you have a
higher propensity of opening up a door
yeah so the more that you open up these
doors the more that continue opening so
if we yes exactly
and again the remember those two those
two sentences they're not reversed
you're not saying this is what I'm
building you're saying I like what
you're doing I want to help you this is
what I'm doing you know it's really
important to have that to have that
order down yeah yeah totally
especially if they're local in the Bay
Area anything in the Bay Area aim to do
in person first aim to do in person
person yeah yep
yeah oh great question the follow-up
email after a cold email hasn't
responded so what I'll do is I'll send
Alex
I'll send Alex a the first email I'll
send him the cold email to sentencer
then you guys he'll send it to you guys
and then you'll get that and you can
mess with that with that template to
sentencer then I'll send you the week
follow-up so if they don't if they go
cold for a week you'll see the follow-up
the follow-up is something like can hate
hate Paul it would be like can can I can
I can I assume that you're not
interested in taking a meeting question
mark that's it
that's it super simple one-sentence
can I assume you're not interested in
taking a meeting and send that off a
week later just like that and and these
are those like there's a lot of nuance
but these are the bind these are like
some of the only times you want to be
very binary in your life you just want
to like give people the option to say no
but you want to know if they're
interested or not and then like yeah
just see if they are not and even if
they don't respond to that follow-up
email just put it in your calendar to
hit them up in two months
I'm serious you have no idea sometimes
people will be traveling they won't even
have internet access and then think
about this put yourself in their shoes
they might be on a honeymoon in Hawaii
you had no idea that they were so the
fact that they got back a week later
when you sent your second follow-up
email and they were parsing their inbox
and they were only responding to
priority things and then your email
didn't get prioritized then you email
them again a month or two later and they
see your email and they go oh this
company sounds interesting I want to
take this meeting so it's not like they
didn't want to meet you it might be that
they were on a honeymoon or they might
have been in Europe or they might have
been trout doing other things really
busy heads down so you never know so
don't don't assume that they're that
they're not interested be persistent be
persistent
and you know like Wayne Gretzky said you
miss 100% of shots in life you don't
take take the risk take the opportunity
take those shots knock on those doors
yeah just there ya know where did the
other thought come may I ask about what
it was yes we'd love to hear from you
that's a great question great question
yes do you know the full potential of
how you can help people because I don't
either
right I don't either I'm trying my best
to figure that out right we were just
talking about this massive network of
tree roots and we don't even know the
extent of our own tree roots
sometimes you can help somebody with a
connection sometimes you can think of
something creatively in that interaction
when they're talking about the way that
their company is working or the way that
they are exploring a partnership or that
they got a partnership where you can say
oh well did you try this and they'll go
I didn't think about that so we don't we
sometimes don't even know how we can be
helpful but when we get that in-person
interaction it's up to us to be really
analytical of how things are going and
be like have we tried this have we tried
that and and make it clear that you're
interested in oh I might have somebody
for that but not in a way that's like I
actually don't but in a way that's like
think I can dig something up I really do
so that's kind of where where I come
from did that help
yeah yeah yeah but you didn't feel
comfortable starting a company either
right yeah did you move to San Francisco
from somewhere where'd you move from
Boston was it easy decision to move to
San Francisco questioning our sanity
every day yeah yeah we all this roller
coaster is crazy and you know you you
took the risk it was very uncomfortable
it's very uncomfortable to start a
company because we know that failure is
just creeping behind our head all the
time that you're hustling other people
are trying to build things at the same
time that are in the same ballpark as
you are
so you're basically hustling trying to
trying to build you know even quicker
you got to invest more hours and be a
better worker more efficient than other
people are as well but also still
getting eight hours of sleep and still
meditate still go to nature still do all
the all the good stuff along the way as
well but if you already took the
opportunity if you took this risk and
this opportunity to stretch yourself
outside of your comfort zone just maybe
say to one out of every two or three
people that you think you might be able
to help more say me I think I can help
as well
you know to start with it a little bit
and see where it goes ahead it's only
email and there's millions of doors
there's millions so what's worst-case
scenario and and even then remember out
of the millions we're still prioritizing
the top five and then the top five after
that and we're trying to find those top
ones we're turning off the connections
to the to the other doors because we
don't we don't want to we want to focus
on the top ones yeah
what's the lowest probability that
what's the probability just randomly you
are going to have some way to contribute
you need like 5 or 10% and worst right
and the other person the superstar they
know how the world works if they decide
to meet you it's because they're willing
to take that bad - right I have a
question so concreted the Sally example
often I find oh I've got like all these
mutual connections with the person but
of course the person I'm closest to and
ask first is like I don't even really
know I'm not sure and so how can one
effectively actually find like those two
links that are sufficiently strong
together yeah
so there there's there's a couple things
here one one of the things that I think
is really interesting about what you're
saying is that we might invest so much
of our time into trying to figure out
those tree root branches and follow them
to the connection when a cold email over
the top might have actually gotten us
the meeting faster so so we we got it we
got to be really careful with our time
it's the most valuable thing so we got
to figure out how to be most efficient
with things and in the case of your if
you are trying to follow the the root
system - the connection then the path of
least resistance first and then follow
that first try if no follow the second
path of least resistance try that yeah
sequentially yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly just be yeah be aware that you
know actually sometimes I will blast
four people or five people with the same
message asking them because you get to
connect me with someone and you know
even if one of them gets back to you
that's great sometimes two or three
might get back to you and they might
maybe maybe two of them make an intro
email great then that person's like okay
wait a second I got to intro emails to
this person like there might be a reason
why I should meet with them
oh it's informal about FOMO fear of
missing out
FOMO love for the for the yeah yes yes
yes
versus like oh look there's so many
people telling me about so the
sequential thing it it's the safe way to
go but in but it's also like how safe do
you want to be you you started a [ __ ]
company you want to take risks so just
take the risk maybe blast out three five
if you really want to be aggressive
blast out ten to the ten mutual
connections that you know and to see who
says yes zero of them might say yes and
then you got a blast ten more so it's
yeah yeah yeah
look look at who you're sitting next to
this your co-founder right are you
married basically but it's it's pretty
damn close though right yeah yeah it's a
dating scene yeah do you have another
thought about it I just want to say
you know you're trying not to be
desperate to be right
you can't go dead against it I want you
know yes correct
yeah that's funny yeah you don't just
welcome to a bar and be like let's have
sex
yeah it doesn't go yeah yeah it's how
can I help you
the time that's good I like the dating
comparison that's that's a good one too
yeah exactly
and you you know like when you are in
search of somebody in terms of like you
know physical emotional mental
attraction what do you what do you do
you you you you you you know you play
you know you play you you you vibe with
them right you don't you know we don't
just do that whole approach we do you
know we do different proach so it's
totally like that yeah
[Music]
and like you know someone that noticed
it and they the gate to get to them was
very high and they hold that connect to
that car very close to the chest yeah
it's gonna take a long time for them to
become one up with you even make that
introduction yeah so like you know just
establishing the friendship establishing
the trust like there's gotta be a
trade-off there right so like any tricks
on like okay you think that's a
superstar that you need to get to but
maybe you even want to get there it's
been for waste of time because it wasn't
the right pathway you should have gone
down in the first place but you had some
crazy thought that was the answer yeah
actually never was yes like how do you
realize yeah that's good since this like
obviously yeah let's go you know in the
pump the brakes and just abort the
mission
right yes
yeah that's good um reciprocation is a
crucial I variable to analyze for breaks
if there's not as so much reciprocation
than we usually slow down a bit but the
superstar so maybe maybe we look at it
in a superstar and then I guess a
richest person on the planet yeah yeah
the Big Bang yeah yeah so so if so if we
if you we if we take a look at the Big
Bang or the or the supernovae if we take
a look at the Big Bang and we look at
you know the connection network to the
Big Bang there is there's like quite a
lot of connections but those people
especially don't like being asked for
[ __ ] so it's there's only a couple big
bangs but there's a shitload of
superstars a lot of superstars so the
you'll actually have a higher propensity
and a higher amount of doors to
superstars and also to you don't want to
risk failure to the supernova or the Big
Bang but you you're fine with risking
failure to just the superstar because
there's another million superstars so so
it's not so yeah totally keep nurturing
and fostering the connections to the Big
Bang's but also the step below that
those those super stars you can pump the
brakes when it when when things like
reciprocation when it's not happening
then you can pump the brakes there or
maybe another time to pump the brakes is
you've had that meeting you've you've
noticed that the value cuz you want it
you want to you want to focus more on
the execution of your business then on
taking all of these meetings that only a
small percentage of them are going to
succeed so you want to really be careful
with your time in terms of taking only
the highest value meetings and then also
knowing when a second meeting is worth
it versus not worth it so then it's up
to you to analyze how that went that
interaction went about how you can help
them how they can help you and if if it
didn't pan out
as well as it should have in your
thoughts then definitely pump the brakes
and explore other ones as well yeah what
was this shirt that Jeff Bezos make it
to respect the trust as someone anyone
so in that way you will your own profit
of
Zack Lee it's the network effect so if
you go out and send a bunch of cold
messages and warm messages trying to get
to your superstars all of a sudden
people would be like well why did I see
you saw you know David - yeah he reached
out to me like a month ago and all of a
sudden they know about you they were
there talking amongst each other and
they know about you
only because you reached out to them
even though both of them might have saw
your message and didn't take meetings
with you they still know of you they
still might have went to your website
and your LinkedIn and looked at stuff so
this is important because you're
planting seeds and these seeds will get
watered over time by different
connections and they'll see more of your
success then all of a sudden they'll
reach out to you for the meeting so
water over time planting the seeds
across the networks also making
introductions for other people as well
building that trusted connection over
time so that way if you see dots
connecting in your network take take the
three minutes to just link both of their
profiles Sally
Paul I really want to introduce you guys
I think there's a lot of synergy let me
know how exploring goes again to
sentence email you've linked both of
their names to their websites or their
linkedin's and you've launched off that
email then Paul and did Paul the Sally
David whoever had said ended up getting
the meetings together possibly possibly
not but then again you're acting as a
connecting node you're building trust
with people over time you're building
your brand your brand is yourself you
are your brand so the more that you can
do your name out there and spend little
bits of time getting your name out there
through things like having this template
Alex I'm going to send you the template
yeah I'm gonna send you the template and
then the follow-up and then you blast it
off to them yes yeah this a great
question I've I've gotten feedback
before about how risky I am with that
and it will it certain people have have
made it clear that they prefer that okay
so if you if if you want to if you want
to achieve greatness ask for forgiveness
not for permission so usually what I do
is I go and take the risk and then
without the double opt-ins and then one
out of every couple dozen people will
email and say hey like I prefer double
opt-ins from here on out and then you
just need to take a mental note that
they prefer double opt-ins opt-in intros
yeah so yeah yep
not done that and I got called out on
this for as well one thing that this is
someone's like hey yo Coleman do you
normally do a double off innings in here
I come back with like yeah that's that's
a great point and also just another
touch point on that is think about how
much extra time it takes to email to
people with those links to the opposite
person's profile wait for both of them
to come back to you maybe one comes back
the other one takes another couple of
days
it's just cluttering you it's cluttering
you it's way better to just ask
forgiveness if it doesn't work out and
just continue going about being a
connector usually you'd be surprised at
how often you think that two people
should synergize and then they do and
then they thank you for it so you'd be
surprised again a lot of us don't know
our full potential
I don't everybody really doesn't and
when we fix start figuring things out we
we get to know the roots of our trees
and how they connect to other roots of
trees and how to maximize again our
superstars the people that we need to
turn connections on to turn connections
off to start figuring ourselves out
better this is going to be the craziest
rollercoaster ride of your lives and
it's the best thing that you'll ever do
and it can be tough sometimes when you
wake up in the morning and you're just
like ah so much to do but every day
you'll get more and more meaning that
you accrue in your life by building this
by building this and by impacting people
when you get those first messages from
people that say like thank you so much
for what you built it's helped me in
this way that you know the way that that
rings in your heart just hold on to
those moments revisit them revisit them
like once a month
and once every week or even every
morning just go and revisit and be like
what I'm building is important and
remind yourself of that and hustle it
out will be the best thing you ever do
and reach out to those superstars make
it happen yeah what is actually so so I
have some not big bangs but supernova so
let's say Big Bang supernova and then
super stars let's say okay so I've had
some supernovas kind of like that middle
tier that have I fell on my face and
they've kind of made their walls a
little higher for me right it doesn't
feel good
hurts but there's also some people that
are supernovae that I did the same thing
for that you know but their walls down
and said huh okay come in so so even
though there are gonna be times that
people are gonna say like you're
wondering about the signals right what
signals they give for you to know that
it's a no yeah okay okay
probably after that third eat the third
maybe third cold email send the first
one sudden the second one a week later
and then he send the third one maybe a
month or two months later if there is no
reply then probably not interested so
also but you can still reach back on
like six or nine months so I'm serious
it's still sluggish back out yeah if you
did a fourth one in like six or nine
months a very very small percentage of
people might be offended but what you
know you you got to be willing to risk
to offend people to pursue execution of
your goals and your vision yeah yeah
because there's gonna be just the very
small people that are like oh I can't
believe that he's emailing me a fourth
time very small percentage of people yes
yeah yeah yeah remember after nine
months they'll be like oh it's a fresh
email yeah yeah yeah on the fourth email
really really said sure yeah that's
funny after the second one where you say
hey I just want to make sure that you're
not interested in taking this meeting
yeah yeah yeah like like hey Katie yeah
I want to [ __ ]
yeah that's a good one
perfect exactly see you guys are smart
you guys can figure this out him better
than I can just keep brainstorming and
working together amongst you to figure
this out that kind of stuffs great hey
Katie just closed this cool partnership
wondering how you're doing
he's still interested in that meeting
that might be the month email a month
down the line or whatever but your email
wasn't totally true it's true yeah
exactly
they some people work on their email at
3:00 in the morning you ever send an
email three in the morning they respond
right away you're like yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah yeah yeah
think about think about how crazy we all
are we all see the status quo of
civilization we see how its shaped how
its formed how its run and we just think
I want to make it better
the other people that you're reaching
out to also think I want to make it
better yeah so you're we're all crazy
here that's why we all took this risk
but not crazy people are the ones that
just choose to live in the in the
civilization the way it's designed for
them and the ones that want to redesign
it to make it better are the crazy ones
and that's good crazy doesn't have to be
a bad thing crazy is a great thing
sometimes
so really embody that feeling I think if
there's a good feeling it's good that's
been great conversation I'm glad you
guys have been engaging and interacting
as much as you have good other thoughts
from people any other thoughts I'm just
I'm just thinking about you're like I'm
thinking about your lists like will you
guys go and and make that list of
superstars okay yeah yeah yeah I want to
get get the list of superstars now it's
not just five superstars for one month
and then you're like I know it's like
five and then you reach out to them and
then you're like oh I finished that in
an hour who are the next five it's about
going and pushing and being persistent
and trying to get as much of the
superstars covered as possible again
remember every time you send an email it
just goes and so it communicates that
signal down the strength of rainforest
tree root system so if you're sending a
hundred to one hundred and these
superstars over the period of a month
it's way more likely that two of them
will connect and be like you get that
email about that company that I really
liked yeah I didn't go meet with them
but etc so you're much more likely to
create the network effect if you go and
hustle out more of this
okay so make that list the superstar
list but also don't forget about the
opposite which is focus focus so turn
off expressions to the people that are
not helping you achieve what you're
focused on you know I don't sometimes I
don't like using this term but it's kind
of like energy vampires get aware of
that heard of that like just a lot of
people like to like to talk to people
that are emotionally intelligent because
then they'll you know you'll reply to
them and you'll be caring for them and
they'll keep reaching out to you because
you care a lot about them and they'll
keep reaching out and all of a sudden
you're in our long conversations with
them and that that that can be a lot and
it's a lot of people are better suited
they literally work in psychology or
sociology and they understand humans
even better and so it's almost better
off to to have other professionals work
at them and let you take that hour to
focus more on your superstar connections
so that's yeah it's it's tough it's it's
a very emotionally tying thing we feel
emotionally tied to those connections
but it's equally as important to turn
those off and to focus time you guys
care a lot about time right yeah okay
it's focusing time is one of the most
important takeaways as well focus focus
focus focus do you guys have do you guys
go long periods of time without with
your phone on silent okay it's like five
of you do any of you
you do yeah good yeah exactly and then
you call them back cuz you're on your
time you're not on someone else's time
so it's true that maybe one of the
superstars you can make a setting on
your phone say that okay
if Sally calls Sally it's a favorite and
if Sally's a favorite then she can break
through your silence if she calls
something like that you can mess with
the settings and figure that out but
generally speaking to be able to focus
on one thing at a time your science your
business development your whatever it
may be focus on that one thing for an
extended period of time of maybe an hour
a couple hours and then go back to email
and then do it because task switching is
very difficult takes a lot of cognitive
resources and also our brains are just
not able to dedicate a hundred percent
to two things at the same time so I'm
sure we've all noticed that the
distracted mind by Adam gazelle II is a
very good book for this and it'll just
it'll change the way you think about the
way we use those devices and the way we
use our computers so you know one task
at a time really go hard on it really
finish that up David what's our time
right now after one after two we started
at one that's right wait Alex did you
say we had until 2:00 right so it's time
over oh oh is the guy in the blue shirt
in the lab with Jun maybe okay so okay
break then thank you everybody
please reach out thank you build our
future you guys are the future build it
build it man thank you very much what
say you
I'm all mo yeah that's what I was iris
oh you do good good hell yeah